question about you know the most
shocking declassified secrets in u.s
history right you got you got this uh
uh uh where you know going into files
and pulling out the top juiciest most
interesting government secrets all of
them have been declassified meaning
governments in question have
uh released documents confirming the
truth fyi folks season two of black
files declassified airing is it
wednesday nine p.m eastern standard time
on science channel and discovery plus
with mike baker you can find season one
of black files the classified is
available on amazon prime i believe a
link is in the description of the
podcast we'll put it below
uh for some of you guys and then maybe
at the end we'll show preview uh of that
so you'll be on the first to see it yeah
so here's here's ten of them we have
okay the u.s relationship with khomeini
okay
declassified records have revealed that
ayatollah khomeini a cleric who would
later emerge as the driving force in
islamic fundamentalism was much closer
to the american government than
previously thought romania has
sought to negotiate with the kennedy and
carter administration in order to ease
his takeover of iran despite his public
anti-american rhetoric going as far as
calling america the great satan i was
there for 10 years when he was ruling
six weeks after he died we left iran and
we went to germany at a refugee camp so
i've watched everything that they were
talking about on tv i was old enough to
remember some of this stuff and the
great satan i mean forget about that
they used to say death upon america look
outside the window and i'd see 10 000
men march flagellating their backs this
is not just like in movies this is stuff
that you actually saw as a kid so how
much credibility is there if romani was
with the cia i mean
if
what do you know about this story he
wasn't with the cia but there was
you know there were efforts to try to
because part of what they were doing is
trying to assess who the hell he is and
you know what his chances are of taking
over what his plans and intentions would
be so there was there was contact right
so you you end up getting contact
reports written constantly you know by
you know i had a chance to talk to him
or somebody meets with him
maybe from state department and then you
sit down and you talk with that person
you say okay what okay what what'd you
guys talk about what what the hell is
going on and so you build up a file the
file doesn't mean that the person's
working for the government i mean you go
down to the archives and basements of
the the agency
and so it sounds like we've got like a
basement i'd like to go to the basement
of the agency it's an event yeah it's a
vault it's it's much like this no i
can't now baker yeah yeah yeah
and so uh so you uh you you know there's
just
file after file of of uh full of contact
reports where you're assessing people
and some of them you know were like this
would think like that's insane there's
no way that this guy's gonna they're not
really it's not like they think we're
gonna target him and recruit him what
they're thinking is we gotta you know we
gotta understand him we gotta know what
the world looks like around him maybe we
can identify somebody who's in his orbit
that we could recruit so there's a lot
of reasons why you would do this but
you know it's it's it's very common now
pat
this is literally your life based on
your childhood
would the cia have motivation to want to
get the sha out of yours okay of course
explain that
can you go pull up this story on the
guardian just
google homey
it's very easy name to spell khomeini
k-h-o
best of luck i like that if your job
depends on the whole name spelling
there you go that one right there so
make that bigger u.s had extensive
contact with the ayatollah that's a
guardian story by the way so with
ayatollah khomeini before we're on
revolution documents seen by bbc
suggests carter administration paved the
way for khomeini to return to iran by
holding the army back from launching a
military coup
uh go okay previously
the leader of the governor excellent he
was in paris for like 12 to 15 years the
bbc reporting suggests that the card
administration took hit of khamenei's
pledges and in effect paved the way for
his return to iran the bbc persian
service obtained a draft message
washington had prepared as a response to
romanian welcome the the ayatollah the
corporation also published a previously
released but unnoticed declassified 1980
ci analysis titled islam in iran which
shows khomeini's initial attempts to
reach u.s
to the uh reach out to the u.s data back
to 1963 16 years before the revolution
the bbc revolution had created a reports
have created a huge role in iran if true
they would undermine the myth that
romani staunchly resisted any direct
links with the us which remained taboo
for three decades until the recent
nuclear negotiations go down to look at
the note go down to look at the note
here let me read above it what it says
about it okay right there other iranian
politicians have also questioned the
bbc's revelations including ibrahim
yazdi khomeini spokesman and adviser of
the time of the revolution saeed
hajarian a former former reformist refu
figure in november 1963 romani
sent a message to united states
government through hajj mirza khalil
kamari a professor of the technological
faculty of tehran university and an
iranian politician
close to opposition as religious groups
romanians explained that he was not
opposed to american interests in iran
interesting on the contrary he thought
the american presence was necessary as a
counterbalance to soviet and possibly
british influence khamenei also
explained his belief in the close
cooperation between islam and other
world religions particularly christian
by the way so he asked the question what
the motivation would be there's a
documentary there's a documentary that
they did on the show
uh fantastic documentary that it's about
oil so they had a 25-year contract iran
did that was coming up in 1979 this was
signed in 1954 matter of fact if you
look it up
uh and you type in 1954
oil
iran do me a favor can you type in 1954
oil iran
um
you'll see it it's called the cons
consortium agreement of 1954
okay that was expiring by 1979
okay and this was with
us british
i think it's germans french and these
guys had a meeting in 76 77 these four
world leaders had a meeting i think in
south or central america
to talk about what we need to do to get
rid of the shot because by 1979 when the
25 years came up he was going to
renegotiate the contract increase the
comp and make more money and they said
this is not good for us we got to get
rid of this guy because he's becoming
too strong and obviously so you're
saying specifically an oil play oh
listen if i'm if i'm everything is
speculation you have to know this is you
know not nothing we know especially
what's going on right now with ukraine
russia we have no clue 100
what everything is going on but my
speculation based on
what i've researched 80 percent of it
was caused because they did not want one
man
to have as much power as he had anything
to get rid of them is what they needed
and then that's what well i guess
i may be wrong so what was the date of
the commanding contact pat what was it
63 november of 63. yeah yeah you know
what that letter started with dear
lyndon congratulations on the new job
sorry to hear about your boss i
understand you feel different about
world political affairs wow
yeah right after november
well we don't know because we need to
know if that is
uh uh what the date is on that but
you're right i really don't have to know
when that date is because it's 22nd
there's that encyclopedia
but there's also i mean you know part of
this is also that the development of the
individual right so you look at 63 then
you look down the road you look at the
mid 70s how
how many changed you know and how he was
developing his his belief system and and
also he was looking in terms of you know
how to control and how to maintain power
and what's that going to look like so
you know you see these and i guess i go
back to the same thing you would see
you know this with other
whether it's castro or anyone else
that's part of what the cia is doing
right they're they're assessing their
understanding that they're looking at
potential lines of communication they're
looking and
but i do think it's it's fascinating the
oil uh
play because i mean that you know you
look at the history of britain uh of the
uk and in iran and
bp the uh
yeah the whole thing is is based on oil
let me ask you before we move on yeah is
it fair to say they got this wrong
meaning whatever hand they had in this
didn't work out well for the world or
iran but depends on who you ask if you
ask the industrial military complex no
there was a war that made a lot of money
with iraq if you ask how about not them
the rest of the world
yeah because this led to
uh them releasing 3 000 political
prisoners
that uh the shah had and a part of it
was the start of
you know osama bin laden and isis and
all that other stuff so he had those
guys he deshawn was concerned about a
couple different parties the extremists
the
uh the you know hezbollah's the isis and
then the other side he was very paranoid
about was today the two-day party the
two-day party was the aoc the communist
party is what it was like think about
far left and far right so there was like
a socialist bernie sanders so he was
worried about the communists and he was
worried about
the isis so when this happened they
released 911 indirectly as a byproduct
of having them being released while the
shah's because you know how people
always bash savage
you know oh savak
savage horrible people okay kgb [ __ ]
once a kgb forever kgb well what the
hell is cia
like
yeah what is ci yeah mike no no no well
no no what i'm saying is but
hold on
but the way we see
kgb and savage is the way iran and
russia sees
cia and mi6 right you know but the way
we say mi6 and cia we kind of said oh
it's nice people to see anybody so
meaning there is patriots
by the way i mean you know i'm i'm maybe
born in iran but i'm made you know i'm
made in iran but i'm you know born
around in america i am i'm about america
but at the same time you know you have
to keep in mind that you know
everybody's buying into some kind of
propaganda so somebody may say right now
hey who gives a [ __ ] about the story i
don't care about iran i don't care about
homemania i don't care about this stuff
what does this have to do with today
here's the point
i don't want to wait
60 years 59 years whatever it is i don't
want to even from 1980 i don't want to
wait 41 years to find out what the hell
is going on with ukraine and russia
i don't know of it either i want to know
what's the cause of covet i want to know
what's going on with ukraine and russia
i want to know what the hell this fouchy
guy was all about i want to know why he
kept saying the same [ __ ] all over again
i i want to know what is going on today
so to the average average person
charlemagne irrelevant but a price was
paid worldwide for a bad decision
and everybody directly or indirectly
whether you know it or not you were
affected by it if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]
you